si no
[Applauso]
ciao a tutti bentornato di the tourist
oggi nuova challenge mai fatto prima e
cioè spiega l'oms in macchina dal
pescara i giocattolini allora spiega
come un intero che senza il es
funzione che all'interno ci sono tanti
ingredienti ingredienti buoni affari coi
denti cattivi quelli buoni sono poli
stanno lì è strano di quelli cattivi ha
scritto la scherza 20 buoni e cattivi
online non so che ingredienti ci sono
preparato su sanità e che abbiamo la
nostra bolidi con la cosa trasparente è
più abbiamo altri dentro solo per oggi
due lord price 2 league li pizzi stati
soppressi che se praticamente noi ne
prendiamo una possiamo scegliere il
palermo allegri denti allora è caduto di
piave parlare di sé tutto solo perché
abbiamo già registrato l'introduzione ma
la camera dovesse funzionare
improvvisamente finire più
per registrare estremamente
impressionante il misto disco di restare
quindi spero che abbiate capito dentro
ci sono invece gli il play ma quali sono
belli alcuni buoni e cattivi come vicino
ce ne sono due che non si ripete ma se
ne sono due che sono fasciati con dello
scotch perché il tavolo perdendo colore
comunque non vi preoccupate non so dove
stia bergamo perché non si vede altre
merci non è così dell'ovetto kinder e
piume di giochi dalle 7 stia morelli
tutti stesso mai perché come mezzo
possiamo scegliere quindi anche
vivamente che dobbiamo cercare di tre
brani più bello possibile perché poi
vincerà chi fa più bello e alla fine del
video vi lasciano fucking sondaggio cui
potrete votare se ho avuto io servizio
vitale in volte alla bellezza info
niente mr delle prime in più oggi io
sono tv pink è vitale team verde quindi
di questa pista in serbia di tale perché
già bestia o me perché mi stanno già
perché ho messo gerber che così non
arriva a studiare
allora mettetevi coi lasciato un bel
live su questo video era giunti di stile
adesso andrò a fare un altro sale jacob
e con la chioma sheen
potete anche questi 10 nei commenti cosa
metterci dentro che ti può disfare
pronto ma mettetevi comodi palle di
revocarle iniziamo più di tutti ok
ragazzi inizia ok mediocre pescare
qualcosa di buono
allora abbiamo un decimo latina
grandissima lettini attenta se noi siamo
per scarichi in tutti dobbiamo
accontentarci di quello che abbiamo
quindi è a tempo quindi dobbiamo cercare
un pescarlo prima che finisca il tempo
altri miei finiscono che le monetine
inizia con la mia prima monetina che
vediamo
primo
[Musica]
adesso abbiamo aggiunge tutto ok allora
non è che un commento qua ora può
capitare è poi il servizio pescarlo
andiamo ad aprire le tutele alle 6 matri
mette la società sono io vediamo
[Musica]
detto
no
[Musica]
roma
adesso
[Musica]
peccato
m niente vediamo un po cosa secco ha
detto wow che fortuna mi sono capitati
glitter viola con le conchiglie viola
bellissimo meno male non mi è capitato
uno schifoso vediamo un po
[Musica]
sembra uno slime sirenetta e viva da est
ha iniziato bene speriamo che continui
bene anche
[Musica]
vendere
no
[Musica]
sono due dato che attesta a pescare
qualcosa
vediamo
[Musica]
a mio
ma passa
a
[Musica]
si no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
una donna aspetta strada libero e arriva
fino radio pescato con con tanto di
vitale e siccome la pellicola sarà un
colorante sarà caduto
vediamo un po che condurrà ai apri tutto
il colore dal colore che vedo non ha una
grandissima tu non sospetta perché io mi
sembra un verde sos per questo sospetto
mi sembra molto fondato qualcuno porterà
le mani purchia le mani di verve al bar
a volerlo che mi sta insegnando dai
butta tutto dentro
vediamo un forte del sé ma perché questi
coloranti certa delle palline dorate
tanto per dei palline occhi e del verde
ha colpito verde petrolio
questo è verde con nero verde scuro per
ora io sono in vantaggio ma vediamo cosa
troverò io là dentro
per il resto tutto come direbbe stato
tutto parte abbiamo dei confetti poi
della frutta degli miles davis bow wow
finora sta facendo benissimo non so da
dove è uscita fuori questa fortuna visto
che intende vince sempre vitale non ti
preoccupare ad un drappeggio speriamo
bene speriamo che continui così perché
finora è bellissimo
[Musica]
lei perché passa il pianto
pronto a spendere tempo
inoltre
sì è vero è appreso il terzo
[Musica]
non ci posso credere
la mostra permette fortunata perché in
genere
se avete visto ho fatto un altro video
con la pro massive in cui pescavo di
sorprendere rives ma ci mette un sacco
di tempo per scarna radici sono io
quello che non sa cosa mi dai qualcosa
[Musica]
noi perché la palla
ma mai lo vedevo servizi accordato
vedere ha pescato un giorno mai quindi
puoi decidere qualsiasi non potevo
evitare avverte però che cosa possiamo
mettere per cercare di vincere abbiamo
delle palline colorate migliorate ci
proviamo almeno dopo 3 di colore ma che
diventa perdi anche quelle che una volta
fortunatissima sono anche caduti
dappertutto tanto di si staccheranno si
staccheranno tutti quanti quando andrai
a marano non ci posso credere che siamo
anche se questi cosa che sono molto
belli tanto male e glister il glitter di
amici non bastano robben
la tua
[Musica]
tutto
ciao
[Musica]
no non finire provo a prendere la morra
dai non dico nè di no
io
[Musica]
quindi forse io cosa mettere deve
scegliere perché sono davvero usciti
l'anno del colore verde dopo che un po
per detto impressionato mostro che
consente questi glitter bianchi tipo
si no bianchi brillanti mossi quindi ora
vado ad aggiungergli vediamo un po
un effetto tipo nelle 5 over prendere
ancora di più
[Musica]
si no
sempre
[Musica]
[Applauso]
troppo lento
[Musica]
andai
questa volta vediamo cosa se qua dentro
allora qua dentro abbiamo pon pon
stelline e glitter gialli wow diventa un
graphic letterato che bene
anche se i pon pon non mi piacciono
tantissimo però vediamo magari fanno un
bell'effetto questa volta
[Musica]
si no
e poi
[Musica]
finalmente
l'ha fatta anche di tale acquistare
qualcosa da paura per ora è una cosa di
guida che perde
speriamo bene cattivo
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sporcarmi all'opzione girata tutta e
shampoo e dai del capitato non vuole
perché in anno con intercetti
eppure tutto c'è dentro la frutta la
frutta
[Musica]
allora proviamo a pulire tutto qua
dentro
faccio il mio speriamo continui ad avere
fortuna
vediamo cos'è cos'è i guizzi con le
letterine e il colorante prossima volta
ciao bello vediamo di che colore diventa
davvero non so come sia possibile che
sono stata così fortunata questa volta
in genere sei solo tu quello fortunato
molto bello ma com'è diventato nota non
ci posso credere funziona a mettere le
magliette del colari i movimenti lo
slide sforzo fatto
[Musica]
no secondo me questa competente nel nome
di sapere che può succedere che sta
scoppiando
via
[Musica]
reilly per rimettere
ps mi sono pentita ha prezzo perché sta
studiando proprio mattina l'ultimo turno
così spina da beppe tra portando capisco
se perdo celeste credo di aver capito
che cos'è
[Musica]
porterò tutte le mani anche vediamo il
colorante verde con la schiuma fino
all'ultimo non ci posso credere ai rosa
o cerca di non dire nostra mente
nonostante ci sia meno verde che rosa va
come è possibile che colore falber di
martina franca di numero sempre quasi un
galaxy galaxy verde sta diventando
grigio ora l'unico modo per salvarmi e
prendere la love qua perché così mettere
il colorante rosa vocazione cosa bergamo
sfida ma questi sono i pon pon però sono
sommersi di brillantini me io pensavo di
avere colto nell'antico l'ora di vabbè
ma non è male da allora un bellissimo
climber dei cake tutte da bandire
[Musica]
beh adesso ve lo facciamo diventare
verde gate dai come diventare
dai anche se mai capitato penso che
sembrava più malate
vedremo questo slime petrolio palude non
certo la lo rifiuta bellissimo il mio
non vedo l'ora di vedere come una volta
che attivo vediamo vediamo
manca poco ormai noi abbiamo quattro
monetine
quindi possiamo provare una volta dato
perché
[Musica]
perché la macchinetta si incastra
perché nel senso che ci faccia perdere
ancora più spesso mi sono montata la
testa
adesso la prendo guarda
[Musica]
ai
oddio la protesta di verde
[Musica]
così ha detto prima io non ti fai sempre
qua guarda ti mandavo sting per dire mai
[Musica]
sta scadendo ha detto
bene
abbiamo tuttavia doveva farmi tanto
[Musica]
no
oddio
più che mai
[Musica]
90 oppure tostate vado più parti per te
non è la sua
no grazie
[Musica]
26 set
perché si blocca su quel
un muretto day
[Musica]
grigio metallo
quindi non so che cosa ma impattando
merico cava forma di comfort anche come
ingredienti assetto ho scelto il
colorante rosa spieghiamo che ora posso
fare andare via tutto questo verde dal
big blind
adesso diventa nero e grigio come un
mezzo un bel po troppo è comprata futuro
ha detto però almeno è rotta e il tuo
ancora verde bellissimo
ora andiamo ad attivabili e poi ve le
facciamo vedere a team siamo sentiti
soli e voi dovrete votare chi vince ecco
qua il miglior live
fortunatamente il verde è andato via e
come potete vedere è un bellissimo viola
poi dentro a cuoricini brillantini
conchiglie un po di tutto il colore mi
piace tantissimo da questo mio
bellissimo e l'ho appena team altro tu
hai mezzo quintale vs borico no tipica
pato
sentite che sony
[Musica]
quindi è tutto la il blues live dategli
pure un nome nei commenti e date il voto
da 1 a 10 per aspetto e persone
vediamo quello di evitare impegnato
bellissimo bellissima guardata allora
anzitutto il colore dal verde si è
trasformato in questo color smeraldo ci
fermeranno c'erano inquinato e con
queste palline che rappresentano tutta
la plastica nell'oceano e dopo a parte
gli scherzi da il colore uscito molto
bene molto grande e super allungabile
morbido e niente e adesso andiamo a
sentire un po gli odori jesi andiamo a
sentire un po i rumori e scoraggiato per
ora attendiamo pochi pochi in due fra
poco
e abbastanza sconfitta adesso invece
facciamo sentire il booking non diamo un
attimino da dai comunque a parte gli
scherzi il colore poi la vedo molto
molto bene
molti italiani
[Risate]
io non capisco perché paghi il po king
c'è ma funziona poco
certo l'ho detto c'è ma funziona poco
lei ha tirato troppo o va benissimo il
suo di booking deve essere un porto deve
essere un po hawking però il muschio ci
prepariamo per il natale e licheni e
tutto quanto non servendo il mio bello
proprio il suolo diventa il mio percorso
elastico grandissimo comunque mi mettono
a questo mezzo votate ho vinto io ho
vinto vitale rovinasse fa 4 castellini e
confiscare per vedere i prostituti delle
nostre altre challenge i nostri video
divertenti che quella che preferite e
buona visione